i do want to look at the recent joe
rogan comments a bunch of people sent me
this and said they would like to hear my
thoughts joe wrote whoa hold on a second
what was that
joe rogan recently
uh saying something about woke something
about woke i don't know let's take a
listen to this
you can never be woke enough that's the
problem it keeps going it keeps going
further and further and further down the
line and if you get
to the point where you capitulate where
you
agree to all these demands it will
eventually get to
straight white men are not allowed to
talk right because it's your privilege
to express yourself when
other people of color have been silenced
throughout history it will be
you're not allowed to go outside because
so many people were imprisoned for so
many years i mean i'm not joking no
that that last thing is a little bit
extreme i'll give you i have to actually
have a lot of thoughts on this but let's
listen to it all no i know it really
will get there
it's that crazy you know we just got to
be nice to each other man
and there's a lot of people that are
taking advantage
of this weirdness in our culture and
then that becomes their thing
their thing is calling people out for
their privilege calling people out
okay so i think joe rogan goes way too
far here
and th this this issue of you know
wokeness and uh
um who gets to speak and all this
different stuff
it it's being dramatically overblown
so here's my take on it um
in general critical let's let me see i
want to make
i want to make this like a seven head
take i don't want to just kind of like
throw out some stuff here i really want
to like address this
because this is a real issue and i think
there's an important conversation here
let me see if i can gather my thoughts
um a lot of these modern
critical theories um that include
critical race theory
and uh others sort of were
birthed by um
foucault postmodernism
and they focus for my take
from for my for my taste and from from
my perspective
uh too much on all narrative
is valid and uh
language okay now the
is the word fucoian is that a word can
someone just
quickly uh uh gut check me on that is
that the term foucaulian
dear god no one knows it is now okay
people know what i mean
the fucoian um a postmodernist idea
was actually a really great thing
for the analysis of literature of
literature
okay the problem that i have
is that when applied to a lot of
other areas whether it's the economy
whether it's race whether it's
a privilege so all these other things
it essentially makes it impossible
for us to say hey you know what not all
ideas are valid
not every narrative deserves an equal
seat at the table
etc and this really goes both ways
because the right loves to critique the
left
along the lines of every narrative is
equally valid and and all this other
stuff
by saying look by the left's
philosophy on this
any understanding about economic
struggles
is equally valid and we can't say that
just doesn't make any sense that's not
based on fact
we don't need to really consider that
okay i heard it it makes no sense
we're eliminating that from the
discussion and
what you get when you're uh driving
a principle is that all narratives are
equally valid
and especially narratives attached
to certain language or certain identity
are
more valid that is a problem
that is a problem and this is not me
going anti-woke or or anything
the the point is that the foucault
ian a post-modernist
ideas which did a lot of great things
for
analysis of literature i don't think are
serving us particularly well in some of
these
other areas and there's one more aspect
to this
okay the focus on language
so like many of you know that i am i am
latino and hispanic or whatever
according to the u.s census i was born
in argentina spanish is my first
language etc
a really big fight right now that's
happening
in some circles and again most people
who just work don't care about this
they really don't and it's also a
movement that's not actually being led
by latino and hispanic people
this entire latinx thing where latino
with the o um is by default
masculine and so there's all these
different
adjustments that some are making uh for
example instead of saying latino you say
latin
x which could be latino or latina or
there's another one where the word in
spanish for everybody is
todos now todos is masculine
if you had a group of only women you
would say todas
there's a new movement which says well
make it t-o-d-x-s
and it's like well but how do you
pronounce that so then when you say it
some people are saying to this with an e
which is not a word
and the idea of this
is if you change the language
to be gender-neutral you will change
society i just don't agree that that's
the case
and so this is another thing that comes
from the the fucoian
school of the importance of language
and i know the idea of if you control
the language you control
people's minds or i don't i think i
don't remember if it was edward
edward bernays or who said that i have a
different view which is
let's actually fix the problems before
the law
when the law is relevant through
education
and then the language will either adjust
on its own
or um it we it will be irrelevant and we
will say you know
i don't really care that the default is
todos which
which is masculine because we've solved
the actual issue of gender inequality
in this area or or in that in that uh
area and so that's my view okay so what
joe wrote
i think joe rogan's going way too far
you won't be allowed to go outside
because people have been imprisoned i
think that's silly maybe he didn't mean
it literally
but i do have critiques
of a critical theory based on
fucoin ideas and the idea of here's the
other problem i have by the way i
apologize if i'm ranting too much
oh i should stop all of this no okay
i'll finish what uh what i'm talking
about
um if you
have a group and by and again the whole
latinx thing
is being driven uh not by latino and
hispanic individuals which
i think matters also to some degree but
regardless of that
imposing that we now use the term latinx
and todas instead of todos or todas etc
in spanish
it's extremely top-down it's not really
the way language develops and
one of the the way that language
typically develops actually if you look
at like new guinean language
new guinean languages um
languages kind of mix and it goes bottom
up is the point i'm trying to make
in new guinea um actually jared diamond
has a lot of great writing on this
because he studied a lot down there
in new guinea you had like i think it's
thousands of different languages
and some of them were spoken by spoken
by really small groups of people
and over time they're developed i don't
know if the word is a patois
or a creole pigeon i think is more of a
pejorative at least in some cases
but the way that it all evolved was
english speakers came over and started
appearing and working with and and
dealing with different tribes and there
started to be like an
averaging in of some american words that
were either spelled differently
pronounced differently or modified
and it's sort of like a bottom-up thing
it's not someone came in and said
we now refer we the word is now latinx
the word is now todas 800-ish languages
okay thank you
um that's i think how that's that's a
much more natural way for language to
change it's the way that language has
changed uh historically so
that's my take all of this to say
um i think joe rogan goes too far let's
listen to it one more time
you can never be woke enough that's the
problem it keeps going it keeps going
further and further and further down the
line and if you get
to the point where you capitulate where
you
agree to all these demands it will
eventually get to
straight white men are not allowed to
talk right because it's your privilege
to express yourself when
other people of color have been silenced
throughout history it will be
you're not allowed to go outside because
so many people were imprisoned for so
many years i mean i'm not joking no
so yeah so he says he's not joking i
mean that's crazy to me i don't think
that that's going to happen
um but i think there are some really
good critiques of what's going on
in some circles in academia right now uh
the focus on controlling language
rather than sort of like fixing issues
in structural ways
and um the idea of every narrative being
equally valid and everybody needs to be
heard and particularly if you attach
certain identities to certain ideas
there are bad ideas they're ideas that
don't need to be heard if you were
trying to figure
out um
i don't even know i'm having trouble
thinking of an example but if you were
trying to figure out almost
anything uh you wouldn't just say
let's bring everybody to the table let's
bri and every idea has to be considered
equally no you defer to actual experts
in some senses in other cases you you
sort of like screen ideas and
etc i think people get it